Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The Kuala Lumpur International Airport in the capital of Malaysia has been likened to a dizzying maze, built on top of what was once agricultural land that sprawls across 100 square kilometres and comprises multiple terminals, buildings and stories. From above, it resembles a giant letter X and was designed to reference Islamic geometry.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。马来西亚首都的吉隆坡国际机场曾被比作一个令人眼花缭乱的迷宫，它建在曾经的农田之上，占地面积达100平方公里，包含多个航站楼、建筑和楼层。从上方俯瞰，它酷似一个巨大的字母X，其设计旨在融入伊斯兰几何元素。
There are two main terminals, both of which are divided into further terminals. Inside, they're sleek and modern with high ceilings and wide glass windows. Every year, tens of millions of passengers from all over the world arrive at the airport and bustle through its halls to check into flights, drop off their baggage and shop until the time comes to board their plane. At 9am on Monday, February 13, 2017, 25-year-old City Aishah was one of many individuals standing in the busy departures hall on level 3 of the airport's second terminal. Known as KLIA2, this terminal was constructed to accommodate various low-cost carriers that
这里有两个主要航站楼，两个航站楼又各自细分为更多航站楼。内部设计时尚现代，拥有高挑的天花板和宽大的玻璃窗。每年，数千万来自世界各地的旅客抵达该机场，在其大厅里匆忙穿梭，办理航班登机手续、托运行李，并在登机时间到来之前尽情购物。2017年2月13日星期一上午9点，25岁的茜蒂·艾莎（City Aishah）是机场第二个航站楼3层繁忙的出发大厅里众多人群中的一员。这个航站楼被称为KLIA2，是为适应各种廉价航空公司而建造的
operate throughout the Asia region. But City wasn't there to board a flight. Instead, the young woman was there as part of a role she'd been given as the star of a reality prank show that was uploaded to YouTube. And she was about to embark on her most thrilling mission yet. City Aishah had relocated to Malaysia from her home country of Indonesia after the breakdown of her marriage. She and her ex had a 7-year-old son named Rio.
这些航空公司在亚洲地区运营。但茜蒂来这里并不是为了登机。相反，这名年轻女子来这里是因为她获得了一项角色，成为一个上传到YouTube的真人秀恶搞节目中的明星。她即将开启她迄今为止最惊险的任务。茜蒂·艾莎在婚姻破裂后，从她的家乡印度尼西亚搬到了马来西亚。她和前夫育有一个7岁的儿子，名叫里奥（Rio）。
Now a single mother, City desperately needed to earn a living so she could provide for him. She left Rio with her parents-in-law and travelled to Kuala Lumpur, where she began working as a masseuse at the sprawling Lakeside Flamingo Hotel. The job only paid about $7 per customer. At night, she undertook sex work, regularly going to a nightclub called the Beach Club Cafe to meet clients. At the beginning of January 2017, City met a taxi driver at the Beach Club Cafe who said
如今作为单亲母亲，茜蒂迫切需要谋生来抚养他。她把里奥留给了公公婆婆，前往吉隆坡，开始在庞大的火烈鸟湖畔酒店（Lakeside Flamingo Hotel）担任按摩师。这份工作每接待一位顾客只能赚大约7美元。到了晚上，她从事性工作，经常去一家名为海滩俱乐部咖啡馆（Beach Club Cafe）的夜总会结识客户。2017年1月上旬，茜蒂在海滩俱乐部咖啡馆遇到了一名出租车司机，他说
he might know of an opportunity for her. He had a Japanese client named James, who was the producer of a popular show that streamed on YouTube. James needed young women to appear on his online series. With her wide eyes, pretty features and youthful face, City was exactly what he was looking for. The driver put City in touch with the James. The very next day, she headed to an upscale shopping mall to meet him in person.
他可能知道一个适合她的机会。他有一个名叫詹姆斯的日本客户，是一家在YouTube上播放的热门节目的制片人。詹姆斯需要年轻女性在他的网络系列节目中出镜。凭借着圆溜溜的眼睛、秀气的外表和年轻的面孔，茜蒂正是他一直在寻找的人。司机将茜蒂介绍给了詹姆斯。就在第二天，她前往一家高档购物中心与他本人见面。
James was young and good looking, but seemed a little shy. He explained that he was behind a hidden camera prank show that had a huge audience in Japan. He needed young women who could carry out practical jokes on unsuspecting bystanders. The pay was impressive. And James was offering the equivalent of $145 per job. The pranks were simple and straightforward. All City had to do was approach men at random, smear their faces with baby oil, quickly apologize and walk away before they even registered what had happened.
詹姆斯年轻且长相帅气，但显得有些害羞。他解释说，他是一档在日本拥有庞大观众群的隐藏摄像机恶搞节目幕后制作人。他需要能够对毫无戒心的旁观者实施恶作剧的年轻女性。薪酬非常可观。詹姆斯开出的条件相当于每完成一次工作就能拿到145美元。这些恶作剧简单直接。茜蒂所要做的就是随机接近男性，将婴儿油抹在他们脸上，迅速道歉，然后在他们甚至还没反应过来发生了什么之前走开。
There wouldn't be any awkward confrontation afterwards and she'd never have to see the person again. City thought the premise sounded absurd. What was so funny about rubbing oil on a stranger's face? But James assured her Japanese audiences loved it. Though City was nervous that someone she pranked might get angry or violent, the money was too good to refuse. She agreed to give it a go.
事后不会有任何尴尬的对峙，她也永远不必再见到这个人。茜蒂觉得这个前提听起来很荒谬。在陌生人的脸上抹油有什么好笑的？但詹姆斯向她保证，日本观众非常喜欢。尽管茜蒂有些紧张，担心被恶作剧的人可能会生气或表现出暴力，但报酬实在丰厚，让人无法拒绝。她同意尝试一下。
But then and there, James took out a small bottle. He poured baby oil on City's hands before she nervously approached her first victim. James watched from a distance, filming the moment on his iPhone. City's heart raced as she walked right up to an oblivious stranger. She raised her hands, smeared the oil across his face and walked away. When she faced no repercussions, City felt a huge surge of relief. She returned to James, who praised her work. With growing confidence, City approached two more victims.
就在那时，詹姆斯掏出一个小瓶子。在茜蒂紧张地走向她的第一个受害者之前，他把婴儿油倒在了茜蒂的手上。詹姆斯在远处观看，用他的iPhone拍摄着这一刻。当茜蒂径直走向一个毫无防备的陌生人时，她的心跳加速。她举起双手，将油抹在他脸上，然后走开。当没有遭到任何反弹时，茜蒂感到如释重负。她回到詹姆斯身边，后者称赞了她的工作。带着与日俱增的自信，茜蒂走向了另外两名受害者。
Both of these attempts went as smoothly as the first. James was impressed. He congratulated City on her efforts, telling her she'd done a great job and he'd be happy to hire her again if she was keen. She was. In just 15 minutes, she'd made 20 times the amount she was paid for each client at her regular job. Over the next few weeks, City met up with James at various shopping malls.
这两次尝试都和第一次一样顺利。詹姆斯印象深刻。他祝贺茜蒂的努力，告诉她做得很好，如果她有兴趣，他很乐意再次雇用她。她确实很有兴趣。在短短15分钟内，她赚到的钱就相当于她日常工作中每个客户所得报酬的20倍。在接下来的几周里，茜蒂在各个购物中心与詹姆斯会面。
They established a routine. James would apply baby oil or lotion to City's hands, then she would approach men from behind and rub their faces while James filmed her. James also had City play pranks at Kuala Lumpur International Airport. Its busy terminal swarmed with people, providing an abundance of potential victims. The work was easy, and over time, James increased her pay. City couldn't believe her luck. She gushed to her friends about how she'd landed on her feet after struggling for so
他们建立了一套常规流程。詹姆斯会将婴儿油或乳液涂抹在茜蒂的手上，然后她从后面接近男性并揉搓他们的脸，同时詹姆斯为她拍摄视频。詹姆斯还让茜蒂在吉隆坡国际机场进行恶作剧。那里熙熙攘攘的航站楼挤满了人，提供了大量的潜在受害者。这项工作很简单，随着时间的推移，詹姆斯提高她的薪水。茜蒂简直不敢相信自己的运气。她向朋友们滔滔不绝地讲述她在经历了这么长时间的挣扎后是如何时来运转的。
long. Moreover, she found herself increasingly attracted to James, charmed by his handsome base and shy personality. He couldn't speak Indonesian, and she couldn't understand Japanese, but the pair communicated to one another by using Google Translate on their smartphones. James told her he might be able to take her to the United States one day. Thrilled, City began daydreaming about the promising future unfurling before her. But, before travelling to America with James, City was referred to another producer named
此外，她发现自己越来越被詹姆斯吸引，被他帅气的外表和害羞的性格所迷住。他不会说印尼语，她也听不懂日语，但两人通过智能手机上的谷歌翻译进行交流。詹姆斯告诉她，他有一天可能会带她去美国。茜蒂兴奋不已，开始幻想着在自己面前徐徐展开的美好未来。但是，在与詹姆斯一同前往美国之前，茜蒂被介绍给了另一位制片人
Mr Chang. He flew City out to Panong Pen in Cambodia to carry out more pranks. Mr Chang was stern and serious, which unsettled City. Despite this, she performed well. Mr Chang was so impressed that he gifted City a $200 bonus. In fact, on Saturday, February 12, he told her that the team was so delighted with her work that they decided to task her with a very important job next time. One that could make her world famous.
张先生（Mr Chang）。他把茜蒂用飞机送到柬埔寨金边去执行更多的恶作剧。张先生严厉而严肃，这让茜蒂感到不安。尽管如此，她表现得很出色。张先生印象深刻，甚至奖励了茜蒂200美元的奖金。事实上，在2月12日星期六，他告诉她，团队对她的工作非常满意，并决定下次指派给她一项非常重要的任务。一项能让她闻名世界任务。
Happy and flush with cash, City celebrated her 25th birthday on Sunday, February 12 by throwing a party at a restaurant. She had already informed her friends of her good news. As they filmed a short clip of their celebrations on her phone, one of them cried out, City is going to be a celebrity. Only the following morning, City met Mr Chang at one of Kuala Lumpur airport's cafes for her next job. Upon seeing her, Mr Chang began explaining what he had in mind for that day's special
心情愉快且手头宽裕的茜蒂于2月12日星期日在一家餐厅举办派对，庆祝她的25岁生日。她已经把这个好消息告诉了朋友们。当他们用她的手机拍摄了一段庆祝活动的短片时，其中一人大喊道，茜蒂要成为名人了。就在第二天早上，茜蒂在吉隆坡机场的一家咖啡馆见到了张先生，准备迎接她的下一项工作。一见到她，张先生就开始解释他为当天这个特殊项目构思的内容。
project. Up until now, every one of the pranks City carried out had followed the same formula. She had approached a man at random from behind, rubbed lotion or oil on his face, then apologised and walked away. This time, Mr Chang wanted something a little different. For starters, he needed City to target a particular man who was going to be at the airport. This individual was a high-ranking boss at his company, renowned for being rude and arrogant. The humiliating prank would be exactly what was needed to take him down at Pegal 2, but
到目前为止，茜蒂实施的每一场恶作剧都遵循着相同的公式。她从后面随机接近一名男子，将乳液或油抹在他的脸上，然后道歉并走开。这一次，张先生想要点不一样的。首先，他需要茜蒂把目标锁定在将出现在机场的一名特定男子身上。此人是他公司的一名高管，以粗鲁和傲慢著称。这场羞辱性的恶作剧正是将他拉下马所需的手段，但
his volatile personality meant he might lash out at City. For that reason, she needed to be particularly careful and get away as quickly as possible after she was done. City had also committed every previous prank by herself. This time, she wouldn't be working solo. Another young woman employed by the show would also be participating and would approach the target from another angle. The goal was for the two to reach him at almost exactly the same time, then flee as swiftly
他反复无常的性格意味着他可能会对茜蒂大发雷霆。出于这个原因，她需要格外小心，并在完成后尽快逃离。茜蒂以往的每一次恶作剧也都是独自一人完成的。这一次，她不会单打独斗。节目雇用的另一名年轻女性也将参与其中，并从另一个角度接近目标。目标是两人几乎在同一时间接近他，然后以最快的速度逃跑
as possible. City was ready. Mr Chang pulled out a small travel-sized bottle. He poured some sticky, greasy fluid on her hands. Then, he steered her towards the bustling departures lounge and pointed out the man she was to prank. He was standing at one of the many self-check-in kiosks, tapping away at the screen to obtain the boarding pass for his flight.
茜蒂准备好了。张先生掏出一个小旅行装瓶子。他把一些黏糊糊、油腻的液体倒在她手上。然后，他引导她走向熙熙攘攘的出发大厅，并指出了她要恶作剧的那名男子。他正站在众多自助值机亭之一前，在屏幕上敲击着获取航班登机牌。
The man was large, balding and middle-aged with an East Asian appearance. He was dressed in a pale gray, expensive-looking blazer and light jeans. A dark, colored backpack was slung over his right shoulder. City's heart beat quickly as she nervously made her way through the crowds towards the man. He looked like a wealthy and important person. What if he called the police? But, though she was scared, City kept going, determined to complete the job.
这名男子身材高大、秃顶、中年，具有东亚人的外貌。他穿着一件浅灰色、看起来很昂贵的西装外套和浅色牛仔裤。右肩上斜挎着一个深色背包。茜蒂的心跳加速，她紧张地穿过人群走向那个男子。他看起来像个富有且重要的人物。如果他报警怎么办？但是，尽管她很害怕，茜蒂还是继续前行，决心完成任务。
She drew closer. When she was no more than two steps away from the man, she saw another young woman cut in front of her and cover the man's eyes with her hands. City joined her and quickly wiped her own sticky, lotion-smeared hands across the man's face. He looked irritated and upset, which did nothing to calm City's nerves. Within a few seconds, the prank was over. The other woman was striding away.
她越走越近。当她距离该男子不过两步远时，她看到另一个年轻女子插到她前面，用双手蒙住了该男子的眼睛。茜蒂加入进来，迅速将自己手上黏糊糊、沾满乳液的手抹在该男子的脸上。他看起来很恼火和沮丧，这并没有缓解茜蒂紧张的神经。短短几秒钟内，恶作剧就结束了。另一个女人大步流星地走开了。
City followed suit, heading in another direction towards a bathroom so she could wash the remainder of the lotion off her hands. Relieved that the particularly tricky job was done with, City decided to grab a bite to eat, then browse some of the airport shops before heading home. Three days later, on the morning of Thursday, February 16, City was at home when she heard a knock on the door. It was the police. They immediately demanded to know where she'd been on Monday morning, asking, Where were
茜蒂效仿她的做法，朝另一个方向走向洗手间，以便洗掉手上残留的乳液。由于这个特别棘手的任务终于完成而感到如释重负，茜蒂决定在回家前吃点东西，然后逛逛机场的商店。三天后，即2月16日星期四上午，茜蒂在家中听到了一阵敲门声。是警察。他们立即质问她周一早晨去了哪里，问道：你在13号去了哪里？你在机场吗？
you on the 13th? Were you at the airport? Saying yes, City explained she'd been filming a video. The officers demanded to know why she had an asked permission to do so. Then informed her they would be taking her to the police station. Believing they were undertaking random checks on international workers, City agreed to go with them. It wasn't until they arrived at their destination that the police officers informed her she wasn't
茜蒂回答“是”，并解释说她一直在拍视频。警察质问她为什么没有获得许可就这么做。然后通知她，他们将带她去警察局。茜蒂以为他们只是在对国际劳工进行例行检查，便同意跟他们走。直到他们到达目的地，警察才通知她，她不是因为违反签证规定而接受调查。茜蒂被控谋杀。
under investigation for a visa violation. City was being charged with murder. Three days earlier, 45-year-old Kim Chul arrived at Kuala Lumpur International Airport shortly before 9 in the morning. He made his way to the departure hall on level 3 of its second terminal. He had a seat booked on a 10.50am flight chartered by AirAsia, a low-cost airline headquartered in Malaysia. Chul was travelling to Macau, the territory on China's south coast where he lived.
三天前，45岁的金哲（Kim Chul）于上午9点前不久抵达吉隆坡国际机场。他前往其第二航站楼3层的出发大厅。他预订了由总部设在马来西亚的廉价航空公司亚洲航空（AirAsia）包机的一趟上午10点50分起飞的航班。金哲正前往他居住的中国南海岸领地澳门。
He was an avid traveller who often documented his adventures on his Facebook profile. He approached the departure board and paused for a moment to stare up at it, checking on the status of his flight. Then, Chul headed towards a cluster of tiny self-check-in kiosks, his backpack slung over his right shoulder. As he stood entering his details on the screen, he was suddenly accosted by two young women. They grabbed him and spread a strange, sticky substance across his face. By the time he realised what had happened, they disappeared.
他是一个狂热的旅行者，经常在自己的Facebook个人资料上记录他的冒险经历。他走到出发信息板前，驻足凝视了一会儿，查看航班状态。然后，金哲朝着一堆微型的自助值机亭走去，他的右肩斜挎着背包。正当他站在屏幕前输入详细信息时，他突然遭到两名年轻女性的纠缠。她们抓住他，将一种奇怪的黏性物质涂抹在他的脸上。等他意识到发生了什么时，她们已经消失了。
Dozens of other people were around, using the kiosks or pushing trolleys full of luggage towards security. One seemed to have noticed the strange attack. Chul was annoyed, but his irritation quickly transformed into terror. His eyes began to burn, pain seared his face, and he suddenly felt nauseatingly dizzy. He realised that the substance the women rubbed on him must have been toxic. He raced towards an information desk to explain what had happened, gesturing to his face with his hands.
周围有几十其他人，正在使用值机亭或推着装满行李的手推车走向安检。其中一人似乎注意到了这起奇怪的袭击。金哲很恼火，但他的愤怒迅速转化为恐惧。他的眼睛开始灼痛，面部传来灼痛感，他突然感到一阵令人作呕的眩晕。他意识到这些女性擦在他脸上的物质一定是有毒的。他冲向问询处解释发生了什么，双手比划着自己的脸。
An airport employee took Chul to a cluster of police officers. Two of them hastily escorted him to the airport's medical clinic. Chul's fate began to drag and shuffle as he walked. Sweat dripped from his forehead and his complexion grew flushed. Soon, his hand-eye coordination started to fail. When he arrived at the clinic, nurses and the airport physician Dr Nick immediately noticed his hands were grasping at his head. Dr Nick asked what had happened, but by this stage Chul was unable to speak.
一名机场员工将金哲带到了一群警察面前。其中两名警察匆忙护送他前往机场的医疗诊所。金哲走起路来步履蹒跚、拖泥带水。汗水从他的额头滴落，肤色变得潮红。很快，他的手眼协调能力开始出现问题。当他到达诊所时，护士和机场内科医生尼克（Dr Nick）立即注意到他的双手正抓着头部。尼克医生询问发生了什么，但此时金哲已经说不出话来。
A check of his vitals revealed his blood pressure had soared and his pulse was racing. His eyes rolled back in his head and he furiously clenched his jaw. He also defecated himself. Dr Nick gave Chul adrenaline and one milligram of atropine. Vomit and blood had to be suctioned from his mouth before he could be intubated. Chul was transferred into an ambulance, but soon fell unconscious. His blood pressure fell to 70 over 40 and his pulse dramatically dropped, then ceased altogether.
对他的生命体征的检查显示，他的血压飙升，脉搏狂跳。他的双眼上翻，牙关紧咬。他还失禁了。尼克医生给金哲注射了肾上腺素和一毫克阿托品。在插管之前，必须从他嘴里吸出呕吐物和血液。金哲被转移到救护车上，但很快就失去了意识。他的血压降至70比40，脉搏急剧下降，随后彻底停止。
He died en route to hospital just two hours after being touched by the two unknown women. An autopsy revealed that a number of Chul's major organs including his brain, liver, lungs and spleen bore traces of poison. A toxicology report subsequently found traces of a nerve agent called VX on Chul's face, which had most likely been absorbed via his eyes. With a name derived from the title Venomous Agent X, VX is an oily yellow-coloured liquid and the most toxic known nerve agent to date. It was developed for chemical warfare in the 1950s and later classified as a weapon of mass
他在被那两个不知身份的女子触碰仅两小时后，在送往医院的途中死亡。尸检显示，金哲的许多主要器官（包括大脑、肝脏、肺和脾脏）都带有毒药痕迹。随后的一份毒理学报告在金哲的脸上发现了名为VX的神经毒剂痕迹，这些毒剂极有可能是通过他的眼睛被吸收的。VX这个名字源于“有毒特工X”（Venomous Agent X），它是一种油状的黄色液体，也是迄今为止已知毒性最大的神经毒剂。它是在20世纪50年代为化学战而开发的，后来被联合国列为大规模杀伤性武器。
destruction by the United Nations. When inhaled or absorbed via an individual's skin, VX disrupts muscle function. It ultimately causes an excruciatingly painful death by asphyxiation. As little as 10 milligrams is enough to kill someone. Chul had received such a high dose of VX that his heart and lungs were affected almost immediately after the assault. The brutal death prompted an inevitable question. Why had someone wanted to poison and murder a man who appeared to be just an ordinary
当通过个人皮肤吸入或吸收时，VX会破坏肌肉功能。它最终会导致极其痛苦的窒息死亡。仅仅10毫克就足以致人死命。金哲受到的VX剂量如此之大，以至于袭击发生后不久，他的心脏和肺部就受到了影响。这场残酷的死亡引发了一个不可避免的问题。为什么有人想要毒害并谋杀一个看起来只是普通旅客的男子？
traveller? Authorities went through Chul's belongings. And his backpack were travel documents confirming his name and date of birth. Chul had been born in the North Korean capital of Pyongyang on June 10, 1970. Also discovered in the backpack was $100,000 in cash and an antidote for poison, which he had apparently forgotten he had on him. But Malaysian authorities already knew that the name Kim Chul was a pseudonym. The truth was, the man who had been publicly murdered in broad daylight at Kuala Lumpur
当局翻看了金哲的随身物品。他的背包里有旅行文件，确认了他的姓名和出生日期。金哲于1970年6月10日出生于朝鲜首都平壤。背包里还发现了10万美元现金以及一种解毒剂，他显然忘记了自己随身携带。但马来西亚当局早就知道“金哲”这个名字是个化名。事实是，这名在吉隆坡国际机场白日昭昭之下被公开谋杀的男子，正是朝鲜独裁领导人金正恩年长的同父异母哥哥。
International Airport was none other than the older half-brother of North Korea's authoritarian leader, Kim Jong-un. The isolationist communist nation of North Korea is notorious for its brutal regime and for having one of the worst human rights records in the world. Since its founding in 1948, three successive generations of the Kim family dynasty have ruled over the East Asian country, adopting the title of supreme leader. The first was Kim Il-sung. He was succeeded by his son Kim Jong-il, who ruled from 1994 until his death in 2011.
这个奉行孤立主义的共产主义国家朝鲜因其残酷的政权和世界上最糟糕的人权记录之一而臭名昭著。自1948年建国以来，金氏家族王朝的三代世袭统治者一直统治着这个东亚国家，并拥有最高领导人的称号。第一位是金日成。他的继任者是他的儿子金正日，金正日从1994年起执政，直至2011年去世。
Decades before he was elevated to supreme leader, Kim Jong-il became enamored with a popular North Korean film star by the name of Song Hee-rim. Although she was already married to a novelist with whom she had one daughter, Kim Jong-il forced her to divorce her husband and become his concubine. Three years later, on May 10, 1971, Song Hee-rim gave birth to Kim Jong-il's first child, a boy named Kim Jong-nam. His existence was initially kept secret, but his father pampered and doted on him, telling Jong-nam he would one day lead his country.
在他被推举为最高领导人数十年前，金正日迷恋上一位名叫成蕙琳（Song Hee-rim）的朝鲜当红电影明星。尽管她已经嫁给了一位小说家并育有一女，但金正日还是强迫她与丈夫离婚，并让她成为自己的情妇。三年后的1971年5月10日，成蕙琳生下了金正日的第一个孩子，一个名叫金正男的男孩。他的存在最初被保密，但他的父亲对他百般溺爱，告诉正男他有一天会领导他的国家。
Eventually, Song Hee-rim fell out of favor with Kim Jong-il and he had her exiled to Russia. Jong-nam was predominantly raised by his aunt and attended boarding school in Moscow, then Switzerland. His father began a relationship with a dancer with whom he had two more sons in the early 1980s. One of these, Kim Jong-un, later usurped to Jong-nam as their father's favorite and upon their father's death in 2011, it was Kim Jong-un who became supreme leader. Malaysian and South Korean news media broke the story of Kim Jong-nam's brazen murder.
最终，成蕙琳失去了金正日的宠爱，被流放到俄罗斯。正男主要由他的姑姑抚养长大，并在莫斯科和瑞士的寄宿学校上学。20世纪80年代初，他的父亲与一名舞蹈演员开始了恋情，并与她生下了另外两个儿子。其中一个儿子金正恩后来取代了正男成为他们父亲最宠爱的儿子，在2011年父亲去世后，正是金正恩成为了最高领导人。马来西亚和韩国的新闻媒体爆出了金正男被公然谋杀的消息。
Suspicions were quick to fall upon his half-brother, North Korea's supreme leader. One South Korean politician described the killing as a, naked example of Kim Jong-un's reign of terror. North Korea angrily refuted the claim, insisting the victim was a citizen by the name of Kim Chul, who had simply died of natural causes. They accused South Korea of convincing Malaysia to help them besmirch the country's reputation. The North Korean ambassador to Malaysia protested against an autopsy being conducted on the victim's body, but was ignored.
人们很快将怀疑对象指向了他的同父异母弟弟、朝鲜最高领导人。一名韩国政客将这起谋杀案描述为“金正恩恐怖统治的一个赤裸裸的例子”。朝鲜愤怒地反驳了这一说法，坚称受害者是一名名叫金哲的公民，他只是自然死亡。他们指责韩国说服马来西亚帮助他们玷污该国的声誉。朝鲜驻马来西亚大使抗议对受害者遗体进行尸检，但被忽视。
In order to confirm the identification, Malaysian officials obtained a DNA sample from Kim Jong-nam's 22-year-old son for comparison. It was a perfect match. His familiar with North Korean politics knew that Kim Jong-nam had long been at odds with the rest of his family. As a teenager, he'd borne witness to a number of public executions. Friends said he struggled with the brutality, and he left North Korea for a time to live in China.
为了确认身份，马来西亚官员获取了金正男22岁儿子的DNA样本进行比对。结果完全吻合。熟悉朝鲜政治的人都知道，金正男长期以来与家里的其他人不和。十几岁时，他曾亲眼目睹过多起公开处刑。朋友们说，他一直在与这种残暴行为作斗争，并曾一度离开朝鲜前往中国生活。
But the final straw came in 2001, when the now 30-year-old Jong-nam attempted to enter Japan using a false passport from the Dominican Republic. He claimed that he'd wanted to visit Tokyo Disneyland. The incident enraged the Kim family, who felt he'd disgraced and humiliated them on the international stage, and two years later, he was exiled from North Korea. Friends who knew Jong-nam have said he was critical of his father's regime, in particular its extreme militarization. Though he became estranged from his family, Jong-nam continued to make money for them via
但压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草发生在2001年，当时年已30岁的正男试图使用一本多米尼加共和国的假护照进入日本。他声称自己想去东京迪士尼乐园参观。这一事件激怒了金家，他们觉得他在国际舞台上让他们蒙羞受辱，两年后，他被驱逐出朝鲜。了解正男的朋友曾表示，他一直批评他父亲的政权，特别是其极端的军事化。尽管他与家人疏远了，但正男继续通过国际商业网络为他们赚钱。
an international business network. Some of these funds were also used to support his Playboy lifestyle. He based himself in the Chinese territory of Macau, but frequently travelled to Malaysia, Singapore, Shanghai, and Europe. He took happy snaps of his adventures and shared them on a Facebook profile he operated under the pseudonym Kim Chow. The majority of his posts were public, making them visible to anyone who cared to view his page.
其中一些资金还被用来支持他花花公子的生活方式。他将基地设在中国领地澳门，但经常前往马来西亚、新加坡、上海和欧洲。他拍摄自己冒险经历的快乐快照，并将它们分享到他以金周（Kim Chow）为化名运营的Facebook个人资料上。他的大部分帖子都是公开的，任何关心他页面的人都可以看到。
In 2011, his father died. Jong-nam's younger brother Kim Jong-un assumed the role of North Korea's great successor, even though he was still in his 20s. Jong-nam outwardly accepted his brother's rise to power. However, in a series of emails he sent to Japanese journalist Yoji Gourmi, he declared Kim Jong-un was too inexperienced to lead, and the country was in dire need of reforms. When Yoji Gourmi published these emails, Kim Jong-un became enraged. Kim Jong-un is an extremely paranoid leader.
2011年，他的父亲去世了。正男的弟弟金正恩接任了朝鲜伟大继承人的角色，尽管他当时还只有20多岁。正男表面上接受了他弟弟的上位。然而，在一系列发送给日本记者藤本健二（Yoji Gourmi）的电子邮件中，他宣称金正恩缺乏领导经验，国家迫切需要改革。当藤本健二发表这些电子邮件时，金正恩勃然大怒。金正恩是一位极度偏执的领导人。
After coming to power, he ordered the executions of more than 140 military officials and politicians whom he considered a threat. They were often killed violently, with machine guns or flamethrowers. Kim Jong-un had also issued a standing order to eliminate any members of his family who might pose a challenge to his rule. He interpreted Kim Jong-nam's words as a direct threat, as well as an insult. In 2011, there were reports that North Korean assassins had attempted to shoot Jong-nam in a cow, but details regarding this botched attack are vague.
上台后，他下令处决了140多名被他视为威胁的军事官员和政客。他们通常被残忍地杀害，使用机枪或火焰喷射器。金正恩还下达了长期指令，要消灭任何可能对其统治构成挑战的家族成员。他将金正男的话解读为直接威胁以及侮辱。2011年，有报道称朝鲜刺客曾试图在一头牛中枪击正男，但有关这次暗杀未遂的细节含糊不清。
The following year, South Korea imprisoned a North Korean spy who admitted to having tried to orchestrate a hit-and-run accident against Jong-nam while he was in China. These attempts on his life caused Jong-nam to fall silent. In 2012, he penned a letter to his brother begging for his life and assuring him that he had no desire to overthrow him. It read in part, Please withdraw the order to punish me and my family. We have nowhere to hide.
第二年，韩国监禁了一名朝鲜间谍，该间谍承认曾试图在正男在中国期间策划针对他的车祸。这些谋杀企图导致正男陷入沉默。2012年，他写了一封信给他的弟弟，恳求饶他一命，并向他保证自己绝无推翻他的意愿。信中部分写道，请收回惩罚我和我家人的命令。我们无处可藏。
The only way to escape is to choose suicide. At his play, Kim Jong-un's paranoia regarding his older brother persisted. Jong-nam knew his life was in danger and shared his fears with a friend six months before his death. He hoped to relocate to Europe where he would be harder to reach and more protected. The Wall Street Journal has reported that he became a CIA source and met with an agent in Malaysia mere days before he was killed. Details of any information he might have provided are unknown.
唯一的逃生方法就是选择自杀。尽管如此，金正恩对这位长兄的偏执依然存在。正男深知自己生命垂危，并在死前六个月向一位朋友分享了他的恐惧。他希望能搬到欧洲，在那里更难被找到，也更能受到保护。《华尔街日报》曾报道称，他成为了美国中情局（CIA）的线人，并在被杀前几天在马来西亚与一名特工会面。他可能提供的信息细节尚不清楚。
Although aligning with the West would have made Jong-nam bill safer, it also would have made him a greater threat to his brother, who feared being overthrown by foreign adversaries. The nerve agent VX was banned by an international chemical weapons convention in 1993, but North Korea never ratified the convention. Experts believe that the regime holds a stash of the deadly nerve agent, which they can draw upon to use against their enemies. The poisoning of Kim Jong-nam led investigators to believe that his younger brother had finally succeeded in disposing of him in the most public and audacious way possible.
尽管与西方结盟会使正男感到更安全，但这也使他对他弟弟构成了更大的威胁，因为他弟弟担心被外国对手推翻。神经毒剂VX在1993年被一项国际化学武器公约所禁止，但朝鲜从未批准该公约。专家认为，该政权藏有这种致命神经毒剂的库存，随时可以调用来对付敌人。金正男的毒害让调查人员相信，他的弟弟最终以最公开、最大胆的方式成功除掉了他。
When Citi Aisha realized that she was being charged with murder, she was shocked and distraught. She claimed to have no idea who Kim Jong-nam was or that she'd done anything other than play a harmless prank. Although she did recall that she had gotten sick after leaving the airport, she'd caught a taxi home and had vomited in the cab. Investigators suspected this was due to traces of VX on her skin. The fact that she'd immediately washed her hands after assaulting Jong-nam had undoubtedly prevented anything worse from happening.
当茜蒂·艾莎意识到自己被控谋杀时，她感到震惊和痛苦。她声称自己根本不知道谁是金正男，也不知道自己除了开一个无害的玩笑之外还做了什么。尽管她确实回忆起自己在离开机场后生病了，但她坐出租车回家，并在车里呕吐了。调查人员怀疑这是因为她皮肤上有VX的痕迹。她在袭击金正男后立即洗手这一举动，无疑阻止了更糟糕的事情发生。
This had identified Citi from CCTV footage that captured the entire attack. Cameras had filmed Kim Jong-nam as he ambled through the airport and made his way to the check-in kiosks. They also caught the moment that two young women flanked him from either side, grabbed his face, and rubbed their hands over it. Both perpetrators strolled away at an easy pace, each heading to a separate bathroom. Close-up footage of the second woman revealed that she had dark shoulder-length hair with a fringe and was wearing a white long-sleeved top with the acronym LOL printed on it in
警方通过捕捉了整个袭击过程的闭路电视画面识别出了茜蒂。摄像头拍下了金正男在机场溜达并前往值机亭的过程。它们还拍下了两名年轻女性从两侧夹击他、抓住他的脸并将双手在上面揉搓的瞬间。两个行凶者以轻松的步伐走开，各自走向不同的洗手间。第二个女性的特写镜头显示，她留着齐肩的深色刘海，穿着一件白色长袖上衣，上面印着用黑色粗体字写成的“LOL”缩写。
bold black letters. Police managed to identify her as a 28-year-old Vietnamese woman named Duong Thi Huyong and arrested her the day before they tracked down Citi. In late December 2016, Hwang had been living in Hanoi when she heard about an interesting sounding job. A friend of hers who ran a restaurant had met a man in his early 30s named Lee who was scouting for actresses. Lee had asked if she knew anyone and Hwang's friend immediately thought of her.
警方成功确认她是28岁的越南女性段氏香（Duong Thi Huong），并在追踪到茜蒂的前一天逮捕了她。2016年12月下旬，香正住在河内，当时她听说了一份听起来很有趣的工作。她的一位经营餐馆的朋友遇到了一名30岁出头的男子，名叫李（Lee），正在物色演员。李曾问她是否认识任何人，香的朋友立刻想到了她。
Hwang had always loved acting and a dream of becoming famous. She'd appeared on the television talent show Vietnam Idol as well as some Vietnamese prank shows and had worked as a model. She met up with Lee and he explained he was making undercover prank videos that took place at airports. All she had to do was pour liquid on strangers as a joke, then walk away. Hwang had happily accepted. Malaysian police were dubious about the women's claims that they'd been duped.
香一直热爱表演，并且有着成为名人的梦想。她曾参加过电视选秀节目《越南偶像》，还出演过一些越南恶作剧节目，并担任过模特。她与李见面，李向她解释说，他正在制作在机场发生的卧底恶作剧视频。她所要做的就是把液体倒在陌生人身上作为玩笑，然后走开。香高兴地接受了。马来西亚警方对两名女性声称自己被欺骗的说法持怀疑态度。
They suspected that two were trained assassins who knew exactly what they were doing and now the hunt was on for the North Korean operatives who helped them orchestrate the attack. The case's lead investigator spoke with Malaysian intelligence officials and was given the names of five North Korean nationals, the youngest of whom was a 30-year-old named Rijie Oo. Checking on Citi's phone, they found a video she had filmed outside a shopping mall some weeks earlier. She was with the James and he was talking her through a prank she had to complete. She scanned her phone across her surroundings, filming tall palm trees and skyscrapers before
他们怀疑这两人是训练有素的刺客，对自己的所作所为心知肚明，现在搜捕的目标转向了帮助他们策划袭击的朝鲜特工。该案的主审调查人员与马来西亚情报官员进行了交谈，并被告知了五名朝鲜国民的名字，其中最年轻的是30岁的李在男（Rijie Oo，音译）。检查茜蒂的手机时，他们发现了一段她在几周前在一家购物中心外面拍摄的视频。她和詹姆斯在一起，詹姆斯正在给她讲解她必须完成的恶作剧。她将手机扫过周围环境，拍摄了高大的棕榈树和摩天大楼，然后将镜头对准了詹姆斯。当他意识到自己被拍时，他向镜头举起一只手，厉声喝道：“关掉。”但她仍然设法拍下了他清晰的面部特写。可以肯定的是，詹姆斯实际上就是李在男。其他四名特工包括34岁的洪松海（Hong Song Haek，曾化名张先生）、33岁的李在黄（Rijie Hwang，曾自称李并与越南嫌疑人段氏香合作）以及两名50多岁的男子。
focusing on James. When he realized he was being filmed, he raised a hand to the camera lens and snapped, turn off. But, she had still managed to get a clear shot of his face. As was certain, James was really Rijie Oo. The other four operatives included 34-year-old Hong Song Haek, who had posed as Mr Chang, 33-year-old Rijie Hwang, who had called himself Lee and worked with Vietnamese suspect Duong Ti Hwang and two men in their 50s.
（注：此处原文第45段与前一段落存在编号重叠及错位，按原始文本块顺序翻译）
CCTV footage from Kuala Lumpur Airport proved that these four men were present at the time of the murder. One seemed to be overseeing the operation and stood at a short distance behind Kim Jong Naam as he studied an arrivals and departures board. Another casually strolled past the airport's medical clinic, pulling a small suitcase alongside him, just as Jong Naam was ushered inside for treatment. By the time they had been identified, all of the men had successfully escaped, either by flying out of the country on the day of the murder or sheltering at the North Korean
吉隆坡机场的闭路电视录像证明，这四名男子在谋杀发生时都在场。其中一人似乎在监督行动，站在金正男身后不远处，看着他研究到达和出发显示屏。另一人随意地走过机场的医疗诊所，身边拉着一个小手提箱，正值金正男被带进去接受治疗的时候。等他们被认出时，所有的男子都已经成功逃脱，要么在谋杀当天乘飞机逃离该国，要么躲在马来西亚当局无法触及的朝鲜大使馆内。
Embassy where Malaysian authorities couldn't reach them. That left City Aishah and Duong Ti Hwang as the only suspects to face criminal charges. Both women were ordered to stand trial for murder. If convicted, they would face a mandatory death penalty. The trial began in October 2017. In August of the following year, the judge ruled that there was enough evidence for City and Hwang to answer for the crime. He was dubious of the defences argument that both women were naive pawns who believed they
这使得茜蒂·艾莎和段氏香成为面临刑事指控的唯一嫌疑人。两名女性都被下令接受谋杀罪审判。如果罪名成立，她们将面临强制死刑。审判于2017年10月开始。次年8月，法官裁定有足够的证据让茜蒂和香对罪行进行答辩。他对外辩护律师的辩词持怀疑态度，即两名女性是天真的棋子，相信自己是一场真人秀恶作剧节目的一部分。他指出，现场从来没有摄像团队，而且她们所谓的恶作剧从来不包括向受害者解释这是个玩笑——这在同类节目中是很常见的事情。
were part of a reality prank show. He pointed out there had never been a camera crew and their supposed pranks never involved explaining the joke to their victims, something commonly seen on such programs. The judge also found their behavior suspicious, such as the way both immediately went to separate bathrooms to clean the remnants of VX from their hands. He ultimately described the murder as a well-planned conspiracy between the two women and the Korean men still at large. While City began sobbing upon hearing the ruling, Hwang remained stoic and straight-faced.
法官还发现她们的行为很可疑，比如两人都立即前往不同的洗手间清除手上的VX残留物。他最终将这起谋杀案描述为两名女性与仍在逃的朝鲜男子之间一场精心策划的谋杀阴谋。当茜蒂听到裁定结果时开始啜泣，而香则表现得坚忍、面不改色。
They would have to wait up to another six months before they would be able to take the stand in their defense. City was terrified of being found guilty, which would certainly result in her execution. As she waited in prison, her physical and mental health deteriorated. She struggled to wait and wept constantly. Her greatest fear was that she would never see her son Ryo again. Then, in March 2019, there was a shock announcement. The murder charge against her was being dropped.
她们不得不等待长达六个月的时间，才能出庭为自己辩护。茜蒂对被判有罪感到恐惧，那肯定会导致她的死刑。在监狱中等待期间，她的身体和心理健康恶化了。她难以等待，终日痛哭。她最大的恐惧是再也见不到她的儿子里奥了。然后，在2019年3月，传出了一个令人震惊的消息。针对她的谋杀指控被撤销了。
The unexpected decision was made after the Indonesian government made a plea for City's release to Malaysia's Attorney General. No reason for the release was given by the Malaysian government. Crowds gathered to celebrate the decision in the rural town where City grew up. Within days, she was flown back to Indonesia. Upon seeing Ryo, City was stunned to see how tall he'd grown in the two years they'd been apart. The two embraced each other fiercely.
这一出人意料的决定是在印度尼西亚政府向马来西亚总检察长恳求释放茜蒂之后做出的。马来西亚政府没有给出释放的理由。人群在茜蒂长大的乡村小镇聚集，庆祝这一决定。几天之内，她被用飞机送回了印度尼西亚。一见到里奥，茜蒂惊讶地发现他在两人分开的两年里长高了那么多。两人紧紧地拥抱在一起。
Now the sole individual facing charges, the Wantee Huang grew distraught. But three days after City was freed, she couldn't sleep or read. The Vietnamese government began petitioning for her release as well, arguing that it was unjust to free one of the women and not the other. On April 1, 2019, the murder charge against Huang was dropped. A deal was struck in which she pleaded guilty to voluntary causing hurt by dangerous weapons or means and was released one month later. The individuals suspected of planning Kim Jong-nam's assassination and coaxing the two
现在成为唯一面临指控的人，段氏香变得心烦意乱。但在茜蒂获释三天后，她无法入睡或阅读。越南政府也开始为她的释放请愿，认为释放其中一名女性而扣留另一名是不公正的。2019年4月1日，针对香的谋杀指控被撤销了。达成了一项协议，她承认犯有使用危险武器或手段故意伤害罪，并在一个月后获释。涉嫌策划金国金正男暗杀并诱使两名女性执行任务的个人从未被捕。
women into carrying it out have never been arrested. In September 2019, City Aishah gave an exclusive interview to the Daily Mail. Although she acknowledged that James had lied to her, she noted that in a roundabout way his promise of making her a celebrity had come true, stating, "...who would imagine that someone like me, who only went to primary school, could become world famous?" Despite Kim Jong-un's fears of being replaced by his brother, sources indicate Kim Jong-nam had no interest in ruling.
2019年9月，茜蒂·艾莎接受了《每日邮报》的独家采访。尽管她承认詹姆斯对她撒了谎，但她指出，从某种曲折的方式来看，他让她成名成为名人的承诺实现了，并表示：“……谁会想到像我这样只上过小学的人，能闻名世界呢？”尽管金正恩担心被他的哥哥取代，但消息来源表明金正男对统治毫无兴趣。
Some North Korean defectors had suggested that he lead a government in exile, but Jong-nam declined. He didn't believe that maintaining power in the Kim family was in North Korea's best interest. Several days before his death, Jong-nam had reached out to an old school friend from Switzerland, letting him know he planned to return to Geneva within the week. He was tired of doing business for North Korea, a task which had become increasingly difficult thanks to his hostile relationship with his half-brother.
一些朝鲜叛逃者曾建议他领导一个流亡政府，但正男拒绝了。他认为在金家维持权力不符合朝鲜的最佳利益。在他去世前几天，正男联系了一位来自瑞士的老学校朋友，让他知道自己计划在一周内返回日内瓦。他厌倦了为朝鲜做生意，由于他与同父异母弟弟的敌对关系，这项任务变得越来越困难。
Jong-nam planned to surrender his North Korean citizenship and relocate to Europe, where he felt safer and could embark on a fresh start. Kim Jong-nam is survived by his six children, including his now 25-year-old son, who was taken into protective custody by the CIA in November 2020. His whereabouts are unknown. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
正男计划放弃他的朝鲜国籍并搬到欧洲，在那里他觉得更安全，可以开始新的生活。金正男留下了六个孩子，其中包括他现在25岁的儿子，他于2020年11月被美国中情局（CIA）置于保护性拘留之下。他的下落不明。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。